want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
two you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
ultimate motivation from marissa pierre
enjoy
the first thing that people who are
incredibly successful do is they do what
they hate
they are fully prepared to do what they
hate
to get to where they want to be and and
people who fail
they will give up their dream before
they do what they hate to do
people who are very successful they
never
ever ever wait for motivation
they do it because when you do it you
become motivated a great writer won't go
well i just wait till i'm really
motivated to start writing this book no
they get up
at four in the morning they don't want
to and they start to write and then of
course they become motivated so you wake
up in the morning and you go
you're not going to go yay it's 5 a.m
i'm putting on my running shoes and
going for a walk
up laurel canyon of course you're not
going to do that you're going to wake up
and go
go i really hate working out but marissa
said
successful people do what they hate to
get to where they want to be
of course the wonderful thing is that
when you do what you hate first enough
times
it starts to become natural like i've
got to do my taxes
i'll do that first thing i've got to
confront someone
i'll do it first and so i still to this
day wake up and think
oh i don't really want to do that so i'm
going to do it first because what i do
want is to belong to that group
of very very successful people so i know
what the membership is
and every time i don't want to do
something i think i don't want to do it
but what i do want is to belong to that
group so i'm doing it first and it's
it's a great way of thinking because
it starts to move you around wanting to
do it for all the right reasons
many many years ago and i met someone
who
wanted to be a rock star that was his
ambition actually particularly wanted to
be a drummer
and he was a very young married man with
two children to support
and he was going for a lot of auditions
and of course all the additions
take place during the day and every time
he had a job they wouldn't let him take
time off so he decided
he would have to work nights in order to
audition during the day
and the only job he could get was a job
he hated he was a taxi driver and he
hated it but he did it
but he just wasn't making enough money
so he thought okay
i'll have to work at mcdonald's i get
more money i can work nights i'm free
to audition and about a month before
he'd applied to work at mcdonald's he'd
been for an audition
to be a drama in a band he didn't even
know who the band was
and the day he was due to start working
mcdonald's which he absolutely hated
even the thought of he got a call to go
you know that band you auditioned for is
actually simple minds and now you're the
drummer and simple mind so he never
worked at mcdonald's or
drove a cab again for the rest of his
life but when he told people that story
they'd all go
ugh i would never work in mcdonald's oh
my god i'd
never degrade myself by driving a cab
around london and i'm like
don't you think you're missing the point
his ability to do what he hated is what
made him a rock star
because he had to have his days free to
rehearse and audition
but if he had your mindset i'd never do
that he would never be
a multi-millionaire rock star it was
because he was fully prepared
to do what he hated to swallow his pride
to keep his vision in mind i want to be
a rock star
i must be free for auditions how can i
do that well i have to work as a cab
driver and in a fast food restaurant
which i hate
i'm going to do it because it's going to
take me to my goal
and it did but the people who laughed
him and said i wouldn't do that
none of them are rock star you can't do
that you'll mess it up you'll never get
it right
you're just not good at that i want you
to change that voice to a cheerleader
a parent who dotes on you a teacher who
thinks you are the best thing in the
world
and i want you to hear that voice saying
yay you can do it
you're amazing this is your area of
excellence you're good at this you know
if you're a kid
running a race at school you'd want your
parent to be going come on come on
you're brilliant you're amazing if you
were doing an assignment at school you
want the teacher or your parent to go
you're very smart
you're really good at writing this is
your skill set
so i want you to become a loving parent
to yourself
a praising teacher a cheerleader that
always goes
yes you can do this this is easy this is
a walk in the park or
you have the skills the talent you've
read that book you know the answers
you've studied
so that's how you stop being your own
worst critic
flip it over and if you're saying i
always mess it up
start to go i get it right i always
forget things i've got a great memory
that's the most important one i don't
like wish wishing says to your mind you
haven't got a prayer but you might as
well wish
because wishing just says you're not
going to do that oh i wish no one says i
wish i could get up in the morning and
clean my teeth
i wish i could pick up that pencil and
write a note
you don't see where she go i'm doing it
so when you say to the mind i
wish i could it says yeah me too get
over it
when you say to the mind i hope i hope i
get this right it goes yeah well
keep hoping because you're not going to
do that when you go if
only am i good as well you've never
managed it before so
keep on with if only why don't you also
if you want to have more self belief and
self confidence
i've designed a special free program to
help you
get it where i send you a video every
day for 254 days
the research says it can take up to 254
days for you to build a new habit and
this program will help you get it once
again it's free
and the link to join is in the
description below successful people do
what they
hate to get to where they want to be
doesn't matter how talented you
are if you don't have self-belief you're
not going to get anywhere
people have a story you know i can't
find a love because my dad left when i
was one
i can't find love because my mum
preferred my brother
i can't be a success because i never
went to university
i can't speak in public because i blush
without understanding when you describe
why you can't
you keep it going if you keep talking
about the symptom your mind
keeps it alive because whatever you
focus on you get more of
and so a lot of people have language
that's completely irrelevant like yes i
know your dad left when you was one i
know your mother
put you up into foster care and didn't
love you but that's
that's then this is now and so they have
outdated stories outdated language that
i can't do that because uh
the classic one i held him oh my god my
boyfriend just ripped out my heart
stamped all over it killed me and if i
find love again it will kill me i'm like
darling he got bored and you would have
got bored too if you'd stuck around
and that was your starter relationship
go and find a better one with someone
amazing everything he loved in you
you didn't take it home with him it's
still there so don't use that irrelevant
i found love and it killed me when it
ended so i found love
the wrong person but i'm going to find
it again with a right person it's going
to be amazing
and compelling he's going to fall in
love with my soul
and he'll be together forever because
you've got to
turn your mind on and it loves exciting
words dramatic words
really loves words that make a picture
so if i said um
to you you can be the most phenomenal
powerful awesome incredible speaker
when you speak on stage everyone stops
so listen you could hear a pin drop they
look at you they hear what you're saying
they like you
the mind goes oh i like this i know
where i'm going here but when you go
i'm not bad at speaking sometimes i'm
quite good occasionally
i really get it right the mind goes what
are you talking about that's not
dramatic enough for me the other thing
very successful people do is that they
they just don't take no for an answer
they get rejected everyone gets rejected
but they come back
they do not take no for an answer and
you know i remember working with luther
vandross in one of my shows and he
unfortunately he's died now and he said
you know people call me an overnight
success richard gere said exactly the
same thing did you know that overnight
success he said it took me 12 years
singing jingles for kentucky fried
chicken
before i got a record deal there is no
overnight success
they get rejected but they come back
over
and over and over again self-esteem
means how much you like yourself but
when you like yourself you also like
other people too you can't like yourself
and not like other people
so a lot of violence and aggression
would end if we could just
learn how to like ourselves and other
people rather than
feel dissatisfied with ourselves which
means of course you're dissatisfied with
someone else because if you don't like
yourself and you feel dissatisfied
you want everyone around you to be like
that too and then you feel a bit better
because you're in the same company
if you don't feel very good and everyone
around you is happy then what you want
what people do is they tend to try and
diminish everyone else or elevate
themselves
but you can't elevate yourself if you
don't like yourself so
a lot of the issues we have in schools
the violence the truanting they're not
achieving could be cut in half
if you just taught children to really
like themselves and to have self-esteem
when you focus on the worst possible
outcome
you actually feel as if you are in that
worst
possible outcome the only way to
overcome a fear
is instead of focusing on the worst
possible outcome to focus on the best
possible outcome
i'm driving it's foggy it's dark it's
icy i might skid off the road and kill
myself
or i'm driving very carefully i'm
driving very slowly i'm driving very
cautiously because i'm going to be
safe and i'm going to get home see
that's the difference you just have to
give yourself different
beliefs the thing with fear always is
you have two choices
rationalize where you feel so terrible
or talk yourself and i was on the beach
with my daughter and there was a big dog
and it was quite a scary dog and
she didn't like this dog and i said to
you know darling when you don't like a
dog
you get very scared and the dog doesn't
like it either and he gets scared so
when you see a scary dog
turn your back to it don't look at it
because when you look at it you're
challenging it
and that's hard to do to turn your back
on a dog but if you turn your back
it's not a challenge and she understood
that
and i was always teaching it when you
have a fear you have a choice
oh my god that dog's going to bite me
attack me hurt me
or i'm going to talk myself i'm going to
turn away i'm going to breathe they're
going to be really calm
and that dog's just going to go on its
way and it's the same with everything in
life to do with fear
rationalize why you feel so fearful or
talk yourself out of it i'll be fine
this is okay
everything's gonna work out perfectly
i'm okay
all of these fears hold you back
and they don't have to because every
fear you go through
teaches you something you see if you go
to a fun fair and go to those loop the
loop rides
you can scream in terror or you can
scream in excitement and the fact that
people put themselves through those
rights means that
at some level we quite like fear it
challenges
us to do more it challenges us to grow
more so don't fear fear remember the
only
fear to fear is fear itself you have to
understand a bit more of psychology
because humans are hard wired to
recreate what they know
we like what's familiar even if that's
very even if it's very bad if i've never
had money
and i win the lottery i'm going to get
rid of it or if i've never had love and
you love me
i'm going to reject you because it's so
unfamiliar if i've had a dad who calls
me an idiot
and worthless guess what kind of guy i
like
that's it because when i meet them i go
oh i feel like i've known this guy my
whole life we just clicked and they
think oh my god it's because he's my dad
but now i've been sleeping with him for
six months i don't know what to do with
that now
because we are wired to like what is
familiar
and to resist what's unfamiliar and
that's what kept us alive when we lived
in waters you didn't go
i'm a bit bored with this group i think
i'll go outside the walled city and find
another tribe because they might have
killed you so we have this wiring that
says
run towards what's familiar and run away
from what's unfamiliar
but the very good news is you can make
anything
familiar and the most important thing to
make familiar is praising yourself
that's if you could just do that that in
itself would change
your entire life how do you praise
yourself
well you get out in the morning and go
i'm a good person
i have a skill i have a town i have
something to offer the world i'm here
for a reason
you look in the mirror and go oh there
you are you're a good person you got a
good heart you know
the most important way to answer that
question is this
what did you always want your dad to
tell you even if you never had a dad
if you had a dad a good dad what would
he have said
what would your mama said what would a
nice teacher have said to you and it
would be something like this
i'm proud of you you're a good son
i'm so glad i'm your dad how lucky i got
to have you
and a teacher would say you're such a
smart kid what a joy
is to teach you because you're smart and
we all want to hear the same stuff
i love you i'm proud of you you're
interesting
you're a great company nobody needs to
hear i'm the best dentist in beverly
hills because that doesn't work
it's emotions and many of my clients
their mother might be dead but they're
still trying to get her to approve of
them
dad's living in another country but
they're still working to make him like
them
and you know the most important thing is
you like you so whatever you wanted to
hear
say it to yourself because your mind
doesn't even know
that it's coming and it also doesn't
care your mind doesn't care what you
tell it is right or wrong
or true or false or even if it's good or
bad it lets it in like
chapstick on your lips your lips don't
go is this organic fair trade
just lets it in it needs a bit of
nourishment
and we need some nourishment and words
are very nourishing and there is
actually nothing on the planet
that will raise your self-esteem like
praise
but self-praise is better because i said
to you i
just adore you you're amazing by the way
you know
can you do this and this and this i've
manipulated you
but if i say it to myself my mind knows
there's no manipulation
and the mind likes repetition when you
say every day your mind kind of goes oh
yeah here you go again with that praise
you say it every day
must be true and now it sinks in in my
experience
people who try to be perfect are the
unhappiest people in the world
and they're almost always the loneliest
too
when you try to be perfect you have
entered a race
that you can't win you can't even
complete it there is no
finishing line the finishing line keeps
moving so when you're in a race to be
thinner
happier richer more successful
you can't complete that race you can't
win it
and instead of thinking oh i'm reaching
my goals you feel intense
dissatisfaction here's the truth the way
you feel about everything is down to the
pictures you make in your head
and the words you say to yourself and
guess what is so great
you can change those pictures any time
you can change those words every thought
you think
every word you say becomes a blueprint
that your mind
body and psyche use everything at their
disposal to make
real thoughts are things what you speak
and think and say without realizing your
mind is working so hard to make that
your reality even if it's super negative
you know i see parents
all the time who say things like i'll be
happy when my kid sleeps through the
night i'd be happy with my kids out of
diapers i'll be happy
when my kid is walking feeding
themselves going to school and they
spend their whole
child's life looking at the next bit to
be happy when you should be thinking wow
i wish every stage took three times as
long you
waste your amazing life wishing it away
for the next bit
because happiness is not a destination
you arrive at
it's the journey you're on it's an
inside job do not
farm out i'll be happy when because
there is no terminal to get to good
happiness
happiness is the journey you're on now
perfectionists come in all shapes and
sizes and they're often
very good at hiding their inner drive to
be perfect
there's one thing that drives them all
and in a belief that says i'm not
enough i'm less than if i'm less than
and i can come across as perfect i'll be
more than
you know my neighbors always say to me
wow you have so many famous clients are
they damaged by fame i'm like
no actually no damaged people are
attracted to fame
they have a belief i'm so damaged but if
i'm famous rich
or just amazing i'll be perfect
could you see what happens when damaged
people try to be perfect
it actually damages them more you don't
need to be perfect
you don't need to be flawless you
don't need to be infallible you just
need to be enough and when you let the
fact in that you are
enough sort of trying so hard to be
perfect
which you can never achieve when you let
in being enough
changes your life so let it in that
you're enough right now
because that's the truth about you every
day you get to choose how to speak to
yourself
you know what you don't get to choose
what you do to your body when you say
i'm an idiot i knew i'd mess that up
i knew that relationship wouldn't work
i've been waiting for it to go wrong in
fact the day we got married
i stuck stickers on all my stuff so when
we got divorced there'd be no confusion
i was already planning the miscarriage i
didn't buy anything for my baby
i mean who does that lots of people
apparently they're all my clients and
they plan
for stuff to go wrong they say i sent my
kid to college and i said don't worry
you're probably going to hate it
here's a credit card so you can get a
return ticket back
in a week's time they plan it
and you don't want to plan it if someone
just comes in and goes i
hate that shirt well that that color is
so not you or you should never have cut
your hair or oh you've got a bit heavy
you just go
thanks for sharing that just a really
simple thing which says
thank you for sharing your opinion which
i can choose to not
let in you don't have to do anything
else when the minute you go
your shirt's pretty awful look at your
hair or calling me heavy you look
you you look anorexic you've let it in
and now you're trying to retaliate and
it's like a game of tennis if you put
down your racket and walk off the court
you can't volley so the first thing to
say is
thanks for sharing that and it's very
good for the little barbs we get
from people family friends sisters
cousins exes
right um if someone is really mean and
says
you know i listened to your talk on
youtube oh my god you stank up the place
i was embarrassed for you then you go
back and you say
i missed that could you repeat that for
me slowly
they were usually not bothered because
they know that in you asking them to
repeat it slowly you're going to call
them out on it
and they usually go oh me and my big
mouth i'm just having a bad i didn't
actually really watch it anyway just
ignore me
and if they do you must not go after
them and go no i want you just repeat it
right now say it to my face
don't do that because a bit like a lion
who bears the teeth they're saying back
off and i don't want to attack you
when a lion bears its teeth you don't go
up to it you walk away it gives you a
chance
to retract so saying could you repeat
that slowly
is giving the person a chance to retract
they almost always do but occasionally
they'll come out and go no
i just said you're so wooden as a
speaker as an insult to wood
people come in and they describe you
know i really want to be successful but
i'd love to be healthier but i want to
find love but i can't get pregnant
because
and the first thing we do is investigate
like a good detective a detective will
lay out pictures and go
what's going on here and they make sense
of it
and very much the same some people come
to me again i've got unexplained
infertility what is that i went well
there's a clue in the in the in the
description it is
unexplained nobody knows your husband's
got crack sperm
that swims straight plenty of it you've
got great eggs
great fallopian tubes perfect womb but
you can't get pregnant because
the the unexplained is here and many
people when they're younger will say
things if i got pregnant my dad would
kill me oh my god if i got pregnant with
the end of the world and
i mean when i was 17 thinking i was
pregnant oh my god no disaster oh my god
my
dad will be so upset devastated
when i wasn't i went oh thank you god oh
yes joy
but you see the mind listens to
everything you
say the mind is always switched on and
it records
everything and it never forgets so
in a moment of absolute terror or fear
or pain or anxiety
there's something called an imprint it
goes in
so a child whose mother says that cat
will scratch you and
give you blood poisoning or that dog's
going to bite you or that's a dangerous
person or
you know i worked a little kid who had a
terrible fear of monsters under the bed
turned out his dad used to say
you'll get run over if you do that
you'll kill yourself if you do that
you'll drown if you do that
turned out his dad was the monster
because he was scaring him all the time
so you get a young person can be an
adult and you get an imprint
and what we do is investigate where
where did this imprint
happen when we've got the imprint which
is very easy you can
ask questions and get the imprint you
can listen to the client's story
the one who said my mum used to cry when
i brought up food and
so happy when i ate or you can use
hypnosis and go back
like that and the reason i love hypnosis
so much is
you go to the imprint you know people
come to see me within five minutes they
have the imprint there's no
oh how does that make you feel and how
do you feel now
and let's talk more about that and come
back next wednesday at form we'll
keep this going because studies now say
that's
that's actually the worst thing you can
do because you just keep the story alive
so we do the investigating we find the
imprint
and then we we interpret it what does
that mean why do you think you know
your dare telling all these stories
would now leave you to
have this monster under your bed why do
you think
at 15 being terrified of being pregnant
could possibly mean that today you've
got an expendability
and they work it out they go yeah now
you say that if i look at those scenes
and look at this scene
it all makes sense and then you
interrupt the belief massively
and then you install a brand new belief
you know you're
getting pregnant like a high school kid
on their first date you're
super fertile you've got crack grade a
eggs your husband's got the
sas of sperm and gonna collide
so you bring in the very powerful
language and you are going to make a
grade
a baby because of course because i want
to be pregnant i'm like
no you don't you want to make a baby
that you carried a full term i have kind
of been pregnant eight times
you want a perfect bouncing healthy baby
so
it's another example of not telling your
mind what you want
so the combination of the imprint the
investigate
the interpret the interrupt and the
install
is so powerfully transformational
what is it about hypnotism that makes it
work is it that people
the things that are freeing them up are
like buried deep in the subconscious
like
why hypnotism why was that the radical
breakthrough hypnosis is the actual
grandfather or even psychotherapy people
think hypnotherapy is the poor relative
and it's come along and it's actually
in front of everything a lot of
hypnotherapists don't understand what
hypnotherapy really means and what it
means is
you can shut down the critical part of
your mind that goes i could never speak
in public oh i could never live without
doughnuts that bit shuts down and while
it shuts down you can excite the
imagination and topical stuff they
simply don't think they could do
so give you an example i was recently
having the medical procedure and the
nurse said oh my god we all know you
and we have this kid and he can't go in
the scanner he's
terrified and i said oh i'll show you
what to do and in five minutes he was
loving being in that scanner
because i taught him listen it's how you
talk just like if you go i feel like i'm
in a coffin here and i'm ill and i'm in
the scanner and it's reminding me that i
could die
and why would you talk to yourself like
that what you say is i
love this this is amazing i've got half
an hour to chill out and
so people don't understand that what
makes hypnosis
powerful is powerful words but they've
got to be
super powerful really dynamic incredibly
relevant
and absolutely up to date and if you
combine that powerful language with
shutting down the critical part that
goes you could never do that who's who's
going to want you you've got four kids
than cellulite
if you shut that bit down and then add
in exciting you can have
anything you want but most people either
don't understand about shutting the bit
down
or they don't understand the language so
without diminishing other therapists i
see a lot of people who say things like
now you might just want to think about
being calm it's like
wtf that's not exciting or they say
things like today
you're going to find it easier not to
eat cake and i'm like
come on we can do way better than that
excite the imagination tell people you
love saying no to cake it thrills you
to pick an apple it elates you to see
the scales going down and your six-pack
emerging because you are
motivated and committed and compelled to
say no to sugar
and if you understand the mind it does
what you tell it
that's its job and if you tell it better
stuff you have an amazing life and if
you tell it mediocre stuff
you have a mediocre life whenever anyone
does anything wrong
we go what's wrong with you we should
say what happened to you what
happened to you and they'll go well you
know my mom always said she didn't want
a girl
boy she wanted a girl and i've been
brought up give an example i had a city
trader as a client
who really had problems trading and his
boss said you know he's the best trader
but he's so nervous
and when i worked with him he said when
he was a kid his parents had two girls
and then him
and he would smash his tonka toys are
gonna go what's wrong with you
look at your sisters just combing their
doll's hair and
they're so good and why are you so
aggressive and a
foyer can't go well because i have
something called testosterone
and they don't and i'm designed to run
and jump and hunt and fish and i gotta
learn
what to do with aggression smashing my
cars together is good for me
he didn't a four-year-old doesn't have
anything because they live in the world
yeah they just live in a world of
feeling not logic and he said i never
realized just spent my whole life
thinking so many things wrong with me
because my parents
so everything comes what's wrong with
you look how neat this is they don't get
peas on the floor when they eat and he
said i heard it every day
until i formed a belief something's
wrong with me he didn't date
women because he thought well i should
be like one
but i want to be like a man and that
session
totally turned him around he said it was
like he someone had sprayed it with
pheromones because he went out that
night when we were attaching himself to
like a magnet
but he just got rid of the feeling of
something's wrong with me
because most people do walk around
something's wrong with me i'm just
majorly messed up
and you can't heal no one understands me
no one gets yeah
and i don't understand me and if i don't
understand me how can you
and why should i even be here yeah
because you can't hear what you can't
understand
and so all the treating the symptom is
like putting a band-aid on an
infection it doesn't when you understand
it
you can totally change your perception
of
what it is because events actually don't
affect you but the meaning you attach
isn't done the story we tell ourselves
the
story and all psychiatrists will tell
you that
and if you want to be sorted out here's
something you must do express your hurt
as close to the event that hurt you
happening as possible you can't say to
your dad
you know 20 years asked for a bike and
you got me a skateboard i didn't want
that
what i worked nights to buy you that
bike
you can't get any resolution after 10
years or 20 years
but when you can say to your friend look
i love you you're my friend but it
really hurt me when you didn't even turn
up to my wedding and i
still had to pay for all of that you
didn't call
and it hurt me i still love you but you
hurt my feelings
then it's gone but when you keep it in
it doesn't when you say to the thing you
make me feel sad anything well you make
me feel angry i didn't come to your
wedding because your guest list that was
extortionate asking for all this stuff i
mean
i'm not bank of america and i don't want
to buy that stuff
but you can't get resolution yeah but
when you say
i was hurt when or i felt hurt by
and you can say it to a wall you can say
it to a force you can say it to a mirror
you can write it down it's not for the
other person it's good to say it because
it's out then
and then it goes away it's the most
wonderful thing it goes away
and then everything is so different we
have a great fear of rejection which is
not surprising because when we're born
we
we have two drivers find connection
avoid rejection after all if a mother
rejects a child if a lion rejects the
cub
it's not going to be adopted it will
just die yeah
where it just starves to death and so we
know innately that our survival on the
planet is linked to not being rejected
and not that long ago you would have
died from rejection you know in
in a thousand years ago when they
banished you outside the walls of the
city or
you marooned a difficult sailor or you
cast someone out of the community you
pretty much
died there was nothing out there but
purgatory so we have a wiring that says
rejection will kill me
and that's why you had the fear but when
you can dialogue with the other look no
it feels like it will kill me it can't
kill me because
no girl can reject me unless i give her
my permission
right give them my power you can't
reject me unless i agree with everything
i don't like you because you've got
short hair i don't like your shirt i
don't like you because you're white not
white tall short
glasses not but when you say you can't
reject me
i'm i can't be rejected because the only
person you can reject me is me
you can talk to girls realizing even if
they say no you're not my type i'm with
someone
no thanks or even ooh not no they can
only reject you if you let that in
and we look at someone like james corden
who's certainly not gorgeous
but women love him because he's funny
so funny and you know we like warm
people you know the
the packaging is all very nice a lot of
people have a great
packaging a great wrapper and it all but
they're unhappy
and so our greatest fear is to be
rejected but the truth is
in 2018 you could live in this apartment
have amazon deliver your groceries never
see a soul and you probably live until
you're 106.
yeah wouldn't i advise it but we don't
die of rejection anymore but we still
feel like we will and all schools should
be teaching kids you cannot
be rejected you can ask for a pay rise
you can ask for crowdfunding you can go
to someone to go here's my idea you can
write a book
speak in public because i with a lot of
actors who say i'm so scared of
rejection i'm like well
how are you going to be an actor then
you should be rejected why don't
you and i write books for everyone who
loves it there's going to be an odd
person because i hate this book and i
hate that writer too
but we don't let it in we have to laugh
about it when you give a youtube talk i
mean i've got
one of my talks about like three million
views and there's a few in there going i
hate her
stuck up english um snob but they don't
know me because that's not me at all but
i don't go oh my god
i can never write another book i can i'm
okay because i don't let it in because
the only opinion that matters is my
opinion i know i'm not stuck up english
snob
so that can't hurt me we have this
belief that our brain's job is to make
us happy oh no
your brain's job is to make you survive
i didn't care if you're happy it cares
if you survive
so when you say my job is killing me
this commute is stressing me out i'm
dying under the paperwork it wants you
to stop
and so because you're my brain's job is
to move you towards pleasure you've got
to say
i love working weekends even if it's not
true i love going to the gym
i'm so lucky i've got a baby that wakes
me up at three in the morning
i know it sounds really pollyanna but
you can trick your mind all the time
i love it i want it i like it and that's
what olympic athletes do when they're
training when they're getting up at 3
a.m to run they don't go oh this is
great
but they also don't come oh my god i
hate it they go yeah this is going to
make me an olympic athlete because they
understand the minds need to move you
towards pleasure
and away from pain and if you link pain
to something your mind will make you
give it up really quickly and people who
fail give up their dreams because they
like pain to them
but people who succeed meet their dreams
they go yeah i want to work all weekend
i'm building a business
i want to work nights writing this books
i'm going to write a book
you can choose what to link pain and
pleasure to in fact you can choose
anything you like but you know what you
can't choose
what happens when you say things like i
hate my job i hate my boss
my in-laws are killing me this kid is
driving me crazy
sure you can choose to say that but you
can't choose what happens when you
are very negative doesn't matter how
talented you are if you don't have
self-belief
you're not going to get anywhere if you
have extraordinary self-belief
very little talent you can get
everywhere but if you have both if you
have talent and belief it will actually
make you
unstoppable and i work with a lot of
football teams a lot of football players
and a lot of those footballers
come out of school at 14 they know
they're going to be famous players
they don't really pursue an education a
lot of them have an extraordinary
negative self belief because
they they're only good at sport which is
a great shame and
one of my players at the moment has now
become a fantastic commentator but i do
a lot of work with him to put in him
that belief because he wasn't great at
spelling and he wasn't great at school
because he knew he was going to be a
footballer
so belief without talent will take you
far further than talent without belief
but if you have both
you can go far but everyone can learn
self-belief
everyone's good at something you know
you're not meant to be good at
everything it's no good being a jack of
all trades and a master of none so
be really good at what you're good at
and don't worry about what you're not
good at
because we're not all supposed to be
good at the same thing
find your talent you know find out what
you love to do what you're meant to do
lies directly behind and is absolutely
linked to what you
love to do when i was a kid actually i
loved writing
little stories and illustrating them and
it's funny that now i am
very successful writer because i was
always writing when i was a kid but i
never considered that as a career but it
kind of found me later
my daughter was always drawing and
always in fact she went to college to be
a criminologist and then gave that up
and became an artist because
it's what she was meant to do so find
out what you love and be
brilliant at it well you are enough is a
movement that i started because you know
33 years of being a therapist i might
work with a movie star an olympic
athlete or someone who's a school
teacher and they all have the same
problem
and the problem is almost always i'm not
enough i mean i've worked with
so many addicts thousands of addicts
i've never met one
who ever thought they're enough they'll
say you know
i drink because i'm not enough i use
because i'm not enough i
am addicted to spending because i'm not
enough and
what i see many therapists doing is the
client comes in with a list like what i
call a shopping list i
i i need to stop drinking i need to get
out of bed i need to stop shouting at my
kids i need to take care of myself
and they like to go through the list it
takes a long time i go oh
forget the list let's look at what what
i call what lies beneath you know your
problem
you think you're enough where does that
has ever you know
any baby who's ever been born because i
shouldn't cry because i don't deserve
attention here i shouldn't
throw up on this white top my mom just
bleached
no baby is ever born believing they're
not enough and so
again we look at where does this come
from this belief you're not enough who
told you that where did you get that and
when they go
oh yes it came from here
it's a game changer because they start
to tell them
i'm enough people say but if i'm enough
don't i just lie on the couch any potato
chips all day
no when you know you're enough then you
go right i need a better relationship
there's a better career than this a
better better health than this
when you wake up in the morning start
going wow this tea
is amazing this coffee is sensational
i love the smell of the shower gel i
love the sheets i love waking up
i had to make myself do this and it
completely changed my life i
wake up and go i love my life i love
being
here my first coffee go i love this
coffee
i love my sheets i love everything and
that's not really true but if you can
make your mind be happy with little wins
every time you eat
something it's sensational
make a phone call go this is great i'm
reading and watching my favorite show
this is amazing
when you sit down at the end of the day
to watch netflix go this is
amazing this is wonderful
you're training your mind to celebrate
tiny little things and when you get big
things
every day feels like christmas you
really can you can stop being ill you
can change the shape of your body you
can change your digestion
you can have physical things you can
change the way you interact with your
kids
so here's a good example my kid is a
nightmare change that to my child is age
appropriate
hmm there you go that's it this builders
are gonna go oh my god that's a disaster
but a good builder goes a challenge when
you said talking to girls is
terrifying you just change that it's
challenging but hey
there's hundreds of girls out there
there's a numbers game one will say yes
and even if they say no the only risk in
life is not to take the risk
that's the risk if you don't say when
you take the risk and it goes wrong you
learn something
now you may have heard many many times
about the marshmallow test and the
marshmallow test is an interesting test
where they took
children and put them in a room with one
marshmallow it's also be done with one
cookie and one pretzel
and they said to the children if you
wait
don't eat that marshmallow then you will
have two
so they were seeing how good these
children were
at delaying gratification because if you
can delay gratification
you are wired for success
and they found one group maybe a third
of the kids just shoved that marshmallow
in their mouth straight away and said oh
i couldn't wait i needed it now they
needed
instant gratification the second group
said no
i'm going to wait and they sat there
knowing that if they waited they got two
marshmallows a third group well they
were interesting because they
they really wanted that marshmallow they
were very much a combination group
wanted to they wanted it
they also wanted to wait as they made
funny faces
they turned their chair around they
tried not to look at the marshmallow
and they forced themselves to wait
and they also got the second marshmallow
so group one
instant gratification group two
naturally
delayed gratification group three were
kind of
programmed to be group one but fought
with themselves until they became group
two
they resisted their natural instinct to
eat the marshmallow
and what they discovered as they
followed those children was
group two and three the ones who delayed
gratification naturally or
completely unnaturally were way
way more successful than group one that
when i need it and i can't wait and i've
got no self-control it looks nice it
tastes nice
bam i've eaten it and now i kind of wish
i'd waited
so i'm telling you this because it
does not matter if you are not naturally
grouped too it only matters that you can
train yourself
teach yourself and help yourself to
become
group two
[Music]
because here's the thing when we're kids
we learn
naturally to delay gratification our
parents say
clean your room and then you can have an
ice cream do your homework and then you
can go to the park
do your chores and then we'll go out and
have cookies
we all do that naturally with children
and then we learn to stop
and you see if you come in from work and
you are naturally a
gratification delay you'll go wow my
favorite
program is on tonight and i'm going to
have this wonderful dinner but
first i'm going to go through my emails
do the stuff that's important and then
my dinner movie
is my reward and what happens is you get
through the way don't do because you're
thinking of the reward you go this is a
reward for doing that
other people come in and go now i'm
going to watch a movie i'm going to have
a lovely dinner and
later i do my emails and of course later
never comes because you had your reward
first
and it is a classic mistake to take
your reward first in powerful language
you can never say you're gonna fall
you're gonna mess that up you're gonna
ruin everything
that's just not going to work out you
have to say the opposite
okay i've only got 10 minutes to prepare
my speech
i only need 10 minutes i've only got 10
minutes to get there that's
exactly how much time i need and if i'm
late
i wasn't supposed to be there on time i
have a belief now when i get to a party
late
it's because it wasn't i wasn't meant to
get there early i no longer oh my god
i'm so late this is going to be terrible
if i was recently going in a cab across
town to get a train to work with a
football team
and we got stuck in traffic and so i was
playing a game i thought oh my god i'm
going to miss the train
this is terrible i'm going to ruin my
reputation the team are going to be
so upset and i felt really sick and then
i started to say
the trains run every 20 minutes it
doesn't matter
what's 20 minutes my material is so
great
they have lots of time after they finish
practicing at three o'clock and and it
was fine
so all the way there i was playing a
game
and i actually got the train on time but
they really wouldn't have minded but i
could have ruined my day
made myself panicky and sweaty by going
oh my god
i haven't got enough time and now it's
all ruined and it's never ruined you can
come back from
anything and then i worked for the
client who had
cancer and had to go into this mri
scanner
and every time i saw him he said i can't
i can't do it i can't get in that
scanner
and i want to say well i feel like i'm
in my coffin i feel like it's a
premonition of my death
and i get in the scanner i think well
i've got cancer
and i'm going to die and what is it what
i freak out i press the button i have to
come out and keep saying look you've got
to go i can't i can't even be in there
for two seconds
which is not true i can't do it for even
a
second he probably was in there for a
few minutes i said look
the words you say to yourself in that
scanner
this is a premonition of my death i feel
like i'm in a coffin
i feel like i'm suffocating and i can't
do it
that's a blueprint and your mind doesn't
like those words so how about these
words
how about saying i'm in my bed at home
and i'm just so chilled and i could lie
here for hours i'm
chilled i'm relaxed i'm blissed out you
must
use words that make a picture you can't
go oh i'm okay really
i'm quite good i'm not bad this is okay
because when i say the words okay not
bad
where's the picture there's no pictures
what i call fluff
when you say i'm chilled i'm blissed out
i'm ecstatic
i'm just lying here and i could do this
for hours it's just
so cool the mind goes you're right and
when you go i'm in a coffin
and i'm suffocating the mind goes you're
right
see here's a great thing you can choose
any word you like you can go well we're
all going to be negative
and this half's going to be positive
that's your choice
you know what you can't choose what you
do
to yourself when you say i'm an idiot
i'm a [ __ ]
i'm a [ __ ] i've got rocks for brains
everything goes wrong who would ever
like me i've got cellulite i'm a single
parent
i've got no chance blah blah blah i
didn't go to college so
i couldn't possibly do what you do i got
kicked out of college by the way so you
can definitely do what i do and it was
the best thing
that ever happened to me i can look at
my life and say being fired
being dumped and being kicked out of
college thank you god for putting that
in
up to me because it changed my life it
was the best thing rejection
has been one of the best things that
ever happened to me
being the least favorite kid if i could
have my life again i'd go back and be
the least favorite kid because i thought
i'm going to show my parents
that i'm something and if i was a
favorite i wouldn't have done that
i would have had a totally different
life praise is unfamiliar
but criticism is familiar when you say
to someone like robin williams oh my god
that last show was funny guys didn't you
notice
i i've left out the visit i fluffed a
word
it wasn't as good as the one before so
if you're
not used to praise you'll reject it and
if you use the criticism you'll add it
in
because we do what's familiar so if we
say to someone
i love your book they go oh actually
it's not that good
the other one is much i love your talk
oh i got it in a car boot sale it's five
years i've got a hole in it
so if we haven't got praise we actually
reject it
and you just have to say to yourself i'm
going to make this familiar i'm going to
praise myself
every day it might feel weird but i'll
keep doing it it's a bit like running
you know running
isn't familiar especially around beverly
hills but if you
put your shoes on and go for a run on
concrete eventually it becomes familiar
and then you like it
i mean sticking a lens in your eye
that's the weirdest thing
the first few times oh my god i'm coming
in my eye like that and then after a
while you can do it
almost without thinking because you get
used to it you can make
anything familiar or unfamiliar
your beliefs affect your body your
beliefs certainly affect your
biochemistry i've had women of 58 say
could you make me pregnant i go
i know it's too late why did you wait 30
years but
the mind will follow your instructions
and
it's very important to give yourself the
right instructions of course there are
limits you can't tell yourself you're
going to be an astronaut
and people said i want to be a
millionaire like what are you going to
do to be a millionaire you can't go i'm
going to sit at home and that's the
problem with the secret
attract millions to you what are you
going to do for these ones i want to be
have a six-pack you do need to go to the
gym i want to have great health well
stop eating pizza and eat better food
but once you get the mind to want it
it's actually easy but when people say
to me i want to be a millionaire
then we tell them well any goal of
significance requires you to learn
something new
but then they have a fear of learning
and and of course you're right then when
people come in and go i want this
you have to look at the blocks the
number one block is the fear of
rejection
if i make it i might get rejected if i
find love they might leave
if i make all that money people won't
like me anymore so you've got to smash
out of the ballpark the fear of
rejection
you've got to smash out the second
belief that says it's all
easy i remember luther vandross saying
you know people say i'm an overnight
success
i sung jingles for kfc for 12 years
it was a long overnight so you do have
to also
have that desire i mean for me you know
i speak in public i write books
always aware that somebody's going to
hate your book i don't like it i'm like
oh that's okay
they can't reject me they might reject
my book most people happen to love them
but to get anywhere in life
you have to get over the fear of
rejection
because people think they're gonna die
from rejection but
they really don't we we tell ourselves
the story we play the only part we've
ever known
and then that part becomes our own and
we don't know how to separate it and so
we'll come in with their story and they
go well you know i nearly i was a
newborn baby and my mom told me that i
was only like two pounds i nearly died
they had to drop milking me with a
dropper and i remember my mum telling me
she used to cry
every time i got weighed or if she fed
me when i threw up they would get so
upset
because i could die like okay and now
you're 600 pounds because you keep
telling yourself that story
and people tell themselves the story
until it validates
why you know my dad didn't love me he
left before i was born he never came to
see me
but he had another kid that you treat
like jesus bought him everything game
boys
clothes so if my dad didn't love me i'm
not lovable
and you have to go but that was then
your dad was an idiot that's nothing to
do with whether you can find
love or not but clients tell themselves
this story
and they don't understand that at any
age you can go well
i think it's time for a new story and so
my job is to first of all find out where
where you know they come and go i don't
know why i do this
i guess i'm just messed up i don't know
why i can't speak i've always been that
way go nope
no baby looks away when you look at them
in the hospital no baby goes don't look
at me
i'm having a bad hair day we're all born
with so much confidence you have four
children they never go night
i can't get a banana in my mouth like i
can't get to grips with this walking
reaching their
wired to go for something
but a lot of damage is done very early
and and i see that
all the time really silly things like
people come in and go you know
i can't ask for money and then rtt has
what i call interruptions after they've
gone back
they have to then say but that's not me
because and that can't be me because and
that won't be me
ever again and what that does is it
starts to change the neurons it's
actually called
neuroplasticity it starts to change the
way the brain is wired
they stop thinking the way they thought
as a child and
put into place different beliefs and
then they're forever changed and it's
amazing to see it in action here's some
things you want to start doing today
right now that will
build your self-esteem super fast the
number one thing
is to praise yourself there is nothing
nothing nothing that will build your
self-esteem like praise but your praises
if you have
a shoppers and so you look really great
in the outfit yeah it suits you you must
buy it
they have an agenda if your boss says
you're amazing at your job but
i need to give you work to do over the
weekend they have an agenda
someone dating you might have an agenda
and your mind knows that
when you say i'm great at my job i'm
smart i'm kind i'm nice people like me
there is no agenda unfortunately when
you go i'm
rubbish at my job i'm boring i always
mess up and i have no friends
your mind lets that into because your
mind doesn't really care if what you say
is right or wrong
good or bad healthy or unhealthy let me
prove that to you
i want you to put your hand in front of
your face like that i want you to close
your eyes i want you to imagine
you have a big fat juicy lemon and i
want you to
breathe in that wonderful lemon smell
and just squeeze it a bit and feel that
wonderful lemon texture because nothing
quite smells like a lemon so still
really believing you have half a lemon
in your
hand open your mouth shove that lemon in
there
cram that half a lemon into your mouth
and start chewing
and sucking and biting and swallowing
the flesh keep
sucking all that lemon flesh into your
mouth bite it
chew it suck out the juice
and you will notice what is happening is
your body is responding to a thought as
if it's
a fact your body is responding to the
image and thought of eating a lemon as
if you are actually eating a lemon
and it's making a saliva because
thoughts are things
and every thought you have has a
physical reaction in your body and an
emotional response to when you think
i don't have friends i can't talk to
people
i can't take things back to a store i
can't ask for special treatment
i don't know how to talk to people then
your mind accepts that as a fact just
like the lemon but when you say
oh i can talk to anyone i'm an
interesting person i'm warm and friendly
people like me and
i can make eye contact i'm good at my
job i can ask someone out on a date
i can tell the person i'm involved with
what i need
your mind accepts that too and someone
recently said they keep a lemon on their
desk now and look at it every day i'm
sure they change it every month
because that lemon reminds them every
day that they
are responsible for what they think and
feeling in your responsibility that word
means an ability
to respond so i want you to start to
praise yourself i want you to wake up in
the morning the first thing you go is i
like myself
we like people who say i've got
something to offer the world
and it's very it's people are very
reassured by confidence you know we're
all scared that
we're going to come across as arrogant
but if you're on a flight and you hit
turbulence you want a confident
pilot if you're sick wouldn't you like a
really confident doctor go
i'm the best doctor in new york i'm
going to make you better you don't want
to go as well
i don't want to brag you know i'm sort
of okay sometimes but you know
he's better than me we don't want our
kids teacher to go well i'm not the best
you know i
have good days we want to go i am the
best teacher
and i'm going to give you back your kid
in a year's time
radiating confidence and talent you know
we pay for that and yet we're so scared
of saying
i've got a gift i've got a skill this
is what i'm good at so here's my advice
to you
expect amazing things then if what is
expected tends to be realized expect the
best
expect love and success and an amazing
life because you know what
it will probably be realized really fast
if you expect it and one of the rules of
the mind and it's the best rule
is that every thought you think
and every word you say forms a blueprint
and your mind must work to make
that blueprint real so when you say
i can't remember anything i'd lose the
eyes in the back of my
head if they weren't fixed in there
because i just can't remember anything
in your mind because that's a blueprint
let me take you to it and when you say
my memory is phenomenal
in fact i'm like human google when i
read an exam
the minute i read the question my mind
has already gone to work
found the answer and i it stays in my
head
right through until i write it on the
paper then i read the next question the
same thing happens as i read the
question google
says here's the answer i work with
children
all the time with exam stress and they
come in i was a little boy last year who
had um
i think there were 17 children applied
for every place
in his school and he flunked the mocks
and i'm like darling
you're supposed to flunk the marks it's
great to flunk the mocks you know what
mocks are don't you
oh so in england when you're taking an
exam you have a mock exam
maybe six weeks before you take the exam
just to see how you do
and then they say well you did terribly
you did really well
and because you did really well you're
gonna pass that exam because you did
terribly you're gonna fail in fact the
ones who do well in the marks get so
complacent
they often don't do so well in the
actual exam the ones who do badly think
wow
i need to up my game i need to revise
more and study more so when he came in
and said my mummy
was so upset because i got really bad
marks in the mark so and that's
fantastic
what were you worth on he said the the
the writing
what did you do is i didn't read the
instructions correctly
and i didn't use the right words but
that's fantastic
so what did you need to do and just by
changing his language i didn't use the
right words
and explained to him that he could do it
and telling him that his mind was like
google then i was asking him some
questions about harry potter
and i said how do you know these answers
have you studied how everybody went no
i just really like it i said well see
how clever your mind is
so when you're working with a kid that
says i don't know ask him about james
bond
ask them about something that they like
and go how do you know this
i don't know how do you know wow you're
so smart
because when they like something they
remember
and part of school is liking something
so with this little kid
he got into that school i knew he'd get
in because he
came in like that and he left like that
he was like i'm gonna
nail this i know what to do my mind is
like
google and i will say to all my clients
whether they're a
seven-year-old taking an exam or someone
taking a medical exam or the bar i say
whatever you're reading your focus
narrows down you
say the word narrow down and when you
say narrow down everything
fades away you're absorbed in that paper
you have
phenomenal powers of concentration
comprehension recall retention
and assimilation and i i say words that
help you the next one
comprehension comprehension retention we
call assimilation i say it over and over
again
because the mind believes what you tell
it how do you help people
establish meaning behind well i wrote a
book called i'm enough and we have a
program
enough and what that does is it takes
you the process of where does this come
from
you're not born with this belief how did
you get
it and when they discover how they got
it they're able to give it up one of my
first ever clients was this
beautiful woman very hard to believe
when she said i can never make a
relationship
last and it sounds so silly but she said
that her dad you said her every day
you'll never
ever find anyone that loves you like me
nobody could love you like me you'll
never
find the kind of love that i have and
he programmed when you label someone you
limit them so now she's got an imprint
i'm never going to find love like this
love and guess what she never found
love like that and all you have to do as
a parent is to say i love you
because you're lovable and all your life
you'll find
love like this love because you're worth
it
so it's little tiny adjustments that
have the most profound
effect on people and it's never too late
to say
i'm enough i can find love and now if
you give someone the power to make you
feel good
you give them the power to make you feel
bad and if you do it to yourself
you feel so much better it makes you
slightly bulletproof you still need
other people we all need other people
but the dialoguing with yourself and
starting with i'm enough
i picked that because i found all my
clients addicts
binges bulimics saboteurs
hoarders compulsive compulsive
shoplifters they all went back to the
same thing
i'm not enough i need more and if you
feel
enough you start to feel equal
see most of us feel unequal you're
better than me because you've got money
or you're more attractive than me but no
dog or cat
says oh you're better than me because
you're a pedigree a baby doesn't know
that another baby's wearing designer
clothes and they're not
they they have no concept of that so
really what i'm enough is doing is
reactivating
and regenerating what you were born with
an ability to say
i'm enough everybody wants to be happy
and we're all
looking to be happy and we seem to have
this weird belief that there's some
destination we're going to get to one
day called happiness but there's no
destination called happiness
there's no terminal you're ever going to
arrive at in your life
called this is the happy place if you
want to be happy and why wouldn't you
want to be happy
here's a way to be happy you've got to
be happy right
now i see so many people that i'll be
happy when my kid can walk
my kid can feed them so i'll be happy
when my kid's gone they're gonna be
happy when
and if you buy into that i'd be happy
when you're never happy because when
never comes i'll be happy when i'm
married i'm single if i could find a
great person i'd be happy and then you
know what you do
you just swap all the problems of being
single to having to compromise with
somebody else
because you have this belief i'll be
happy when so if you want to be happy
here's how to be happy decide to be
happy right now don't do that i'll be
happy
when i get to my holiday i'm super
stressed at the airport i'm having a
management but when i get there
i'll be happy because now you've told
your mind that happiness
is somewhere you're going to tell your
mind the truth
i am happy right now i've decided to be
happy in the moment
i'm choosing to be happy you see your
mind is set up to do what you tell it
and every time you say to him i'd be
happy when it believes that happiness is
out there and you're going there but you
might never get there when you go
i'm happy right now i'm happy packing
i'm happy at the stress of the airport
i'm happy
this minute i am choosing to be happy
then your mind understands the truth
happiness is
now you're not going to happiness you're
not looking for happiness and by the way
nobody else can make you happy while an
amazing partner
a great career a wonderful kid will
enhance your happiness
if you give that to someone else my
partner is going to make me happy
having a baby is going to make me happy
having a great job where i get
recognized going to make me happy
getting praise is going to make me happy
you know what you're doing
you're giving someone else a
responsibility to make you happy and if
you say to them
here you go you make me happy that will
work for a while but then
you know what you're giving them you're
giving them power to make you unhappy
i want a little baby to be happy and i
got it but now that baby
is a 14 year old teenager doesn't want
to speak to me
people say oh you know you make me feel
amazing and then the other side of that
is you make me feel so angry and so
lonely and so unimportant don't
give your power to be happy to anyone
else
it's up to you and don't wait to be
happy
choose to be happy right now in the
moment
i mean look at little children the rain
makes them happy a
puddle makes them happy everything makes
them happy
because they live in the moment
happiness is an inside job
go inside you live in the moment i
promise you
if you make a decision i'm going to be
happy right now
no matter what and everything i do
you'll train your mind to be happy
what do you use what do you think is
your greatest challenge that you face
internally personal challenge as someone
who's
helped thousands tens of thousands of
people personally um
yeah i suppose it's not a challenge to
get more people to understand it because
people need it you know we all need to
be nourished you know we need
inter we need nourishment our soul needs
to be nourished it's not about organic
avocados from one market that's great
but we all need this emotional
nourishment so
is it a challenge getting more people to
accept it i don't
think it is because everyone i see oh my
god i love that and some although you
know i
i listened to you thought that's rubbish
but then i found myself going into the
garage
and saying nice stuff to myself so
[Music]
maybe my only challenge but even then
it's not a challenge is i would say half
the medical profession love what i do
and really go for it oh my god this is
amazing i'm using it with my own
patients the other half get this is all
silly
you know illness is caused by disease
that you can't talk yourself better
talking to yourself doesn't make any
difference you can't possibly give birth
just using positive affirmations it's
like if if you had cancer and you had a
very good oncologist you might go look
you know the way you think
the way you eat the way you act the way
you rest can all affect and go nope you
got cancer
chemotherapy there's nothing else that
will work and
all that stuff is hocus pocus so that is
a challenge
but it's not so much because i find so
many doctors
love what i do and go wow you know all
these illnesses are autoimmune illnesses
many years ago there was a wonderful
psychiatrist in london
called dr mortally and he had a great
expression it's always been my favorite
and it says
the feeling that cannot find its
expression in tears may cause other
organs
to weep so he knew 100 years ago that's
beautiful
so beautiful and so true the feeling
that
cannot find its expression in tears will
cause other organs
to weep so he's sort of saying if you
don't feel the feeling
your body's gonna feel it if you don't
open your mouth
and say you hurt me don't be surprised
if you get a screaming everywhere i've
got this screaming headache
i've got this angry red rash i've got
this thumping pain
and by the words they're using angry
screaming they're saying i have
rage that can't come out that's pressing
it but it's kind of
pressed through yeah because the body is
very clever at finding something
i worked with someone who couldn't walk
and all ships i can't stand there
i can't stand my ex i can't stand my
life i can't stand my kids and you can't
stand up
isn't that interesting she had sort of
phantom
leg pains because she couldn't stand
anything bulimia's also what makes me
sick is
my sister-in-law i'm so sick of her she
just makes me sick
i vomit in my mouth every time i hear a
voice and then they wonder why they
believe it
right because our words that really
affect our reality
partly because and it's such an easy
thing to say
every word you say is a blueprint
that your mind body and psyche are
working to make your reality
so we we make our thoughts and our
thoughts make us then we go out into the
world and we justify our thoughts every
day
but we our words are a blueprint and
when you know they think well i better
pay attention to that blueprint i better
not say this kid is killing me
my job is making me want to die
i'm so stressed out by what the queue in
hughes market
well go to zimbabwe where there is no
hughes market
and there is no queue and there's no
money to buy food and then you can say
you're stressed because
your problem the cue in erawan and the
bill
is someone else's fantasy dream come
true you
this freeway is killing you you have a
car
you haven't look at people on four buses
i used to take my daughter to school
when i'm in one day thinking that
oh my god this commute is hell and i saw
someone at a bus and thought how lucky
i'm in my car
i've got the heating i've got a cup of
tea i've got an
hour to listen to some i could talk to
my kid i keep saying one and a half to
myself well here it is
and i learned to stop doing that but
when you said how are you a
nightmare it is torture what the traffic
yeah the traffic the queue people keep
ringing me the phone ringing it's
torture well
maybe if it didn't ring that might be
worse
some of my clients or models will say my
life is hell because people look at me
it's like really well one day they won't
and then you might miss it
if i get on a plane a guy's hit on me
it's a nightmare well put on a baseball
hat
and glasses ready to breathe and they'll
leave you alone
but that's not a nightmare it's just
mildly inconvenient it's not
hell right it's not killing you but we
use these incredible words this is
torture this is killing me this isn't
like this is a disaster
what is well i went to the bathroom and
i forgot to pause my movie
that's not a disaster but when you use
those words because your mind can't
differentiate to feel like it really is
a disaster
there's a certain rules of your mind
that i like to operate from and one is
the mind learns by repetition
so nobody would go to the gym and go
i've done 500 sit-ups i should have a
six-pack now you know you've got to go
back and do them again
and do them again once you get that
six-pack you can keep it with
a little less repetition and so it is
with how we dialogue with ourselves you
know
my passion is to get schools to teach
children to dialogue with themselves
better so repetition is very important
but it's not quite enough you know if
you were a chronic alcoholic and said
right i'm going to say every day i don't
drink i don't drink i don't drink
that probably won't work first of all
the mind doesn't know what don't is when
you say i don't drink it's like saying
i'm not thinking about chocolate you
have to think about the word that's most
descriptive in the sentence it's like
saying
don't think of an orange snowman now
you've got to think of an orange name
and even if you've never seen one in
your life
so the combination of repetition
powerful words can be more than enough i
mean
somebody wrote to me and said my kid was
lying on the floor hysterical about her
exams and
i played one of your audios and she got
up here i'm going to ace this and she
went
she did ace it and i could tell even by
the set of her chin that
she knew but for many people
they need more they need you to go back
and unpick their story why
do you do what you do what happened to
you
why are you an alcoholic in
understanding why
for most people that's their aha moment
they go oh my god i never knew that's
why i do that oh
and then you add in and now you know you
never have to do it again
so you always have a choice your mind
talks to your body all the time that's
its job and your job
is to tell your mind what you want i
want perfect health
i don't do illness i do wellness
everything i do is perfect
you know i was at a conference reasoning
someone wrote oh my god i'm so glad i
listened to your audio because you know
i have
four hours of sleep and i tell my mind
i'm having eight and i thought i should
do that i'm teaching people this i
forgot i can do that too
tell my mind i had a hour's sleep tell
my mind i feel amazing tell my mind when
i'm working out my body
loves this my muscles love this i can do
a bit more
rather than go oh it all aches and i
hate doing this and i could be at home
watching tv
so just to be very clear your mind's job
is to do what you tell it and your job
should you choose to accept is to tell
it great things amazing things
i'm not aging i'm saging i'm and
i'm embodying wellness i have perfect
balance you can choose
not only does the mind tell the body
what to do
it also interrupts the signals coming
back from the body i've got this
crippling thumping headache can become
one i've got a little niggle in my head
but i'm really too busy to notice it
i'm in agony no you've just had a little
shot that's not agony this commute is
hell
no hell is not having a car or any gas
and looking at people or taking three
buses to do your commute being in this
store is torture
no when you go to africa and you see
they don't have any stores and the ones
they do have no food in them you'll
never again stand in ralph's and go this
is a nightmare
it's hell grocery shopping if you have
money in your wallet to buy food of
people that love you
that is so far beyond hell but people
use these words it's killing me it's a
disaster it's a nightmare
my best ass is that i i don't do no i
refuse to take no for an answer so if
i'm told no
you know and i thought you can't have a
baby or you'll never be able to do that
i don't i don't let that in which i find
very useful
um i do letting criticism but only if
it's useful
and so i'd say that's probably my best
attitude i just won't take no for an
answer and i was studying once um
celebrities because there was a lot of
them
and i mean i don't put myself in that
category but what i found out was that
celebrities don't take no for an answer
they're very interesting
they simply refuse to do no and if you
say to them okay we're having a party
everyone's coming wearing white they'll
turn up in green because they want to be
a little bit different but they don't
see it as a handicap they see it as an
asset
and it's a it's a great thing to not
take no for an answer
you know we used to live in ward cities
and and
our strength came from numbers we we
were in a group and
with numbers we survived now you can
live in an apartment
you can have cats and dogs you can have
your grocery store you can never see
anyone
and you could live till you're 110 but
we still
feel this feeling i'll die if you reject
me
no you won't you'll get stronger but you
know
for women especially if you went back
500 years ago
you're a hunter-gatherer and your guy
died out spearing a wildly beast you
would die who's going to raise your
children who's going to feed you
so in our evolutionary psychology we
have this fear
i'll die if you don't like me and we try
to get over it by buying stuff and going
to the gym
and having our hair down or getting a
nicer car
or trying to impress people and what you
should do is impress upon your mind look
i know you think i'm gonna die from
rejection
i'm not actually it's gonna make me
stronger and if you can
dialogue with yourself and go okay just
been dumped
i feel a bit sad it's not gonna kill me
it's that was a starter relationship the
next one is going to be
way better then it does make you
stronger
people think the brain is really
complicated it's not it's actually quite
simple you need to know three things
about your brain to always get what you
want and the first thing is your brain
does exactly what it thinks you
want it to do because it listens to
everything you say so when you say
things like oh god you know i got dumped
it's so painful
i never want to go through that again
all your mind can pick up is you you
don't want to be in a relationship
again when people have a miscarriage and
go i could never never go through that
again
i'd rather die than go through that
again your mind is picking up oh right
well that's
that's a statement that's actually a
command to me to make sure you never go
through a miscarriage again
and that that's how you get unexplained
infertility
which is something else i've been
working on a lot recently
because the mind listens to what you see
so we will go oh i went on this fly i
thought it was going to die
and do it again i'm never getting
replayed if this plane lands i will
never
ever get on a plane again and of course
it lands like oh it's just turbulence
but next time they go to the airport
have a massive panic attack because your
mind's like hang on a minute
you said i never want to fly again
and so if you haven't got what you want
it's because you're giving your mind
very confusing
messages your mind's number one job is
to listen to what you say
to interact on it his second job is to
move you towards
pleasure and away from pain and it will
always always always do more to avoid
pain so let's imagine you've
gone for an interview you've done a
public speech thing like me and you've
stood up and you've got
a uh and he said oh my god i'm never
doing this again
and you'd have a terrible presentation
and one of my clients who worked for
sonia was saying that she had to stand
up and just say to sony this is a new
band from camden and she stood up and
went this is a new band from
and they're called uh i couldn't do it i
just
was the simplest thing and my boss had
to take over
and that i was explaining to her that
when you do that and go oh my god i
don't i don't want to do it i don't want
to do this again your mind is now going
to make sure you don't do it again so
the next time you go to speak it will
give you a panic attack it'll make you
ill
and if you say to yourself oh my god i'd
love a week off in bed or
i'm dreading next wednesday your mind is
so in tune with you your week off in bed
you wake up with a flu anyone's like
there you go
how cool am i there's your week in bed
you don't want to go to that speech
i've woken you up with diarrhoea so now
you can't go
that's what the mind does when i was
giving my first ever presentation
about my first ever book i woke up with
the most excruciating mic i've never had
one before i thought wow
i must have been saying to myself
somewhere i don't want to do this
because i've got this migraine and i
actually went and did it and i didn't
have the migraine until i stepped back
off the stage again
and i realized that i'm was
communicating very badly with myself
so you must never say nervous say
excited because your mind listens so
those three things
are your mind does what it really thinks
you want to do if you're very very
specific and say i want
this and this i want to be a great
speaker i want to
deliver things i want to be fantastic at
sales i want to be able to look people
online
sell them things and come across as
really authentic
your mind will understand and if you
make those pictures
really good and pleasant you'll move
towards them
when there is a battle between logic and
emotion emotion
always always always wins how many of
you've gone
to a really high building an enclosed
building like the top story of a hotel
or
the cn tower in toronto and looked down
and thought oh
wow i feel really scared my logic my
nose
i'm safe that the glass is that thick
that i can't fall
but the emotion that's making my stomach
lurch is
winning so when you have a battle
between emotion and logic
emotion always always always wins
here's something you all know we can all
ring our friend go i'm a bit bored a bit
lonely
can i hang out or i'm a bit bored let's
go to the movie you would
never ring someone you've just met and
go i'm bored and lonely
will you come and hang out with me let's
go to the movie because the emotion
that you might be rejected will overrule
the logic that says this person
may be the person for me so if you're
having a
battle between yourself here's a great
one
i know i shouldn't eat cake that's the
logic but the emotion is
oh the cake feels so good and this
creamy sugary stuff reminds me being a
baby
when all my needs were met by having
creamy sugary stuff
so in a battle doing emotion and logic
logic will
never win emotion will always win
and you can make that win for you by
making it a better emotion so here's how
to do it
here's an emotion i'm scared to ask for
a pay rise in case my boss
laughs me out of the office make it a
stronger emotion
if i go to my boss and show them what
i've done
how valuable i am that won't happen
here's an
emotion i really want to ask that person
on a date
i'm not good enough change the emotion
i'm wonderful
i'm amazing what could i get from asking
someone on a date that says yes
so much and if they say no i'm only
exactly where i was before
except i've been brave i've done
something courageous i've taken action
even if it doesn't work out
i've lost nothing but i've gained
courage so when you're having a battle
doing logic
and emotion emotion always wins
logic never wins that's why you could
stand on the windowsill of your
apartment if it was on the ground floor
but you would never stand on the
windowsill
same size if it was a hundred stories up
because the emotion
that you may fall defeat the logic that
says i can do this when it's a few feet
off the ground
why can't i do it up here because
emotion
overrules logic you can make your life
phenomenal
extraordinary and wonderful by
always using emotion to defeat emotion
every baby on the world is worn loaded
with self-esteem no baby
when they're being pushed down the
street in their stroller goes oh don't
look at me i'm having a
bad hair day or i've just been sick on
my little romper suit or
i've got really fat legs baby's first
experience on the planet is being looked
at when you're born
the doctor the nurse the midwife look at
you family come to visit you
you get your picture taken people show
you off and babies don't avert their
eyes when you take their picture
when i used to push my little girl down
the street look in her pram go oh my god
she's so gorgeous she never looked away
she kicked her little legs
she gave a big gummy smile because she
knew that she was gorgeous too
and if you ever doubt that children like
attention
go to a park go to a swimming pool in
your hair every juggling mummy mummy
look at me on the swing daddy watch me
on the slide mummy mummy watch me
jump in the wood watch me swim watch me
jump because children have this belief
that
i'm worthy of attention and i like it
and i can ask for it and i'll get
it and then you have to ask well where
does that go
well it goes very fast you know if i
said i might have a girl look to
sing my mummy a song she would sing if i
said her 14
sing me a song she'd roll her eyes and
go oh my god you're so embarrassing
and walk out of the room because at a
very early age we require
fear of being judged it's what is called
performance anxiety
what if i sing and someone laughs at me
what if i read in class and i get it
wrong
what if i stand up to speak and i don't
know what to say
performance anxiety can be so intense
that it makes us
stop performing but people who perform
really well
like themselves oh i'll see what happens
and
i'll sing i'll dance i'll act i mean
some people can't even dance at a party
in case everyone is looking at them
and judging them badly some of my
clients won't even go to yoga in case
they can't hold the poses like everyone
else and believe me
we're all so busy worrying about us we
don't have time to look at you
and comment on your yoga position or
how you're dancing at a party and we
kind of like people who don't care who
just
let go and have a good time so the thing
you need to have phenomenal confidence
really are two things
stop judging yourself and be nice to
yourself
you mentioned something about
leaning into the feelings until if you
no longer need to feel them or before
they go away
feel the feeling that it no longer
requires to be felt
why do we why should we do that so give
an example okay
so let's imagine you you and your
ex-wife are not getting on
and you have a feeling of rage about the
fact that she's
trying to get your kid to call a new guy
daddy and she's blocking you out and you
feel
so angry you think i mustn't feel angry
you know
she's doing it for the interest of my
kid or and so i just drink the anger and
i drink the anger and you see with a
feeling
it's the most real thing you have a
feeling is like a little kid in a class
going
notice me i'm over here and if you don't
they get more and more out of control
and so when you don't acknowledge your
feelings they regroup
and they regroup until they become
outraged rage
coming out and then suddenly they go a
bit crazy in the car park of the store
or the line of the store because the
mind says
i've got all this rage wants to come out
someone just cut into the line
take it out on them and it's so
ineffective because i have something i
call triple a which is
be aware of your feeling most people
have no idea what they feel like i
shouldn't feel jealous
i shouldn't feel envious i shouldn't be
furious with this kid
who's keeping me up all night so they're
not aware of it
they certainly can't accept and they
never get to articulate
if you can say you know my wife's a good
person but actually i'm furious
with what she's doing it really hurts my
feelings that's why group therapy
in places like aaa the good thing is you
get to say
sometimes i could quite cheerfully
um hurt my wife i'm not going to but i
feel like
oh yeah i feel like that too because
when you can express your feeling
it goes away it goes away immediately
but when you indicated
yeah even to yourself so if your
mother-in-law is the absolute [ __ ] from
hell
and you can't say by the way dorothy you
are the most horrible mother-in-law in
the world
but you just go and shut yourself in the
bathroom turn on the taps flutter
and say dorothy is a really unpleasant
mother-in-law
and one of mine yeah you feel so much
better because
you're not saying it to them it's like
feelings are like gas
they're in or they're out and they hurt
much more when you keep them in
and you want to let them out maybe
gasoline obviously around the middle of
a meeting but
when you keep stuff in it causes you
pain is something that will change your
life if you make it familiar
praise yourself say i did a great job i
did a good job
you know the days of startup where
you're running your own business it may
take
two years before you see a profit
the only person who's going to praise
you the end of every day is you so say i
did a great job
did a really good job i love what i'm
doing i'm good at it
make praise familiar for very successful
people
if they have to fire someone if they
have to make a very
uncomfortable phone call they will do it
first
and what's interesting is that they
naturally do that they would say
things like well you know i've got to
end a partnership with my best friend or
i've got to fire someone i really care
about
i couldn't possibly have that hanging
over my head all day i need to do it
first then it's done
and then i feel better people who are
not in that group will go oh god i've
got a
fire like my friend i'll do that at six
o'clock i'll wait till the end
i do that after lunch or i've got to go
and do a grueling workout i do that at
five o'clock but of course five o'clock
comes and you have a phone call to make
or you've just had lunch and
then you don't get to do it even in
school i mean one of my clients who was
very successful said yeah when we had to
you know read out an essay i never
understood the kids who
who went last i put my hand up and went
i'll read the essay first because
i want it done so they do it naturally
but
that doesn't matter because of course
the wonderful thing is that when you do
what you hate first enough times
it starts to become natural like i've
got to do my taxes i'll do that first
thing i've got to confront someone
and i'll do it first and so i still to
this day wake up and think oh i don't
really want to do that
so i'm going to do it first because what
i do want is to belong to that group
of very very successful people so i know
what the membership is
and every time i don't to do something i
think i don't want to do it but what i
do want
is to belong to that group so i'm doing
it first and it's
it's a great way of thinking because
it starts to move you around wanting to
do it for all the right reasons
i always say to all my clients there's
only three things wrong with everyone
everyone has got three things wrong the
number one is i'm not enough
the second one is i'm different so i
can't connect and the third is i really
want something like freedom from
depression
or success but it's not available but
i'm not enough is the biggest
i mean i've worked with hundreds of
thousands of addicts i've never found
one ever that
ever believed they're enough and if we
look at the key addiction
shopping binging on food
binging on alcohol binging on drugs sex
sex especially porn all of those
things come from a feeling of emptiness
inside because we're taught oh you feel
a feeling
why don't you eat some donuts so go on
to ebay and buy or amazon buy something
or
have a drink and our feelings are the
most real thing we have
and we push them down we find all this
stuff to buy or eat or drink or
take to keep us like john lennon said
comfortably numb
but then the feelings regroup and come
back because they've always got a job to
do
and i would say to my clients look
you've got to feel the feeling until
it no longer requires to be felt you
can't eat it
or drink it or shop it away but we're
all taught that we can and should
so i'm not enough is the biggest problem
you can only love another person to the
degree that you
love yourself and another person can
only love you to the degree that they
love themselves and so if you go through
life feeling you're unlovable
that will always affect the quality of
the relationships you have
and if you date or marry or live with
someone who thinks they are unlovable
it's very hard to have a really healthy
great relationship with the person you
are with
feels unlovable of you at some deep
level think that you are unlovable and
more
problems occur from people attracting
the wrong relationship
staying in the wrong relationship
because they feel unlovable i see people
in our office
time and time and time again who were
the wrong person
and they're too scared to leave in case
they won't find someone else they said
well we've been together for so long
what's the point but everything changes
when you know that you are lovable
and you see lovability is essential to
being happy
and i have many people who go well you
know i've never felt love being loved is
just a foreign country to me
i don't know what love is i've gone
through my whole life
never having had love and marilyn monroe
bless her heart
somebody said to once marilyn what is
this thing about you wearing those
really tight dresses and
dancing out of all of those soldiers
with everything hanging out she said i'm
going to quote
her word for word i need the whole world
to love me
i must belong to everyone because i've
never belonged to anyone
or anything in my entire life and i
probably never will and there was a girl
who was
beautiful stunning engaging
everybody loved marilyn except marilyn
but you see
if you can't love yourself nothing
really matters
since we're sharing here you do know
don't you that people who are critical
have so much criticism reserved for
themselves they
actively dislike themselves and you're
actually showing me
and the entire office that you really
don't like yourself
like critiquing yeah by creating you're
just showing me yeah critical people
always have criticism reserved for
themselves they
are full of self-criticism but they
reflect it out and
superior people and happy people always
praise and people who feel inadequate
always
criticize because criticize withers you
and praise builds you
up and if you can use those five clinics
thanks for sharing
could you repeat that are you trying to
hurt my feelings won't work i'm not
letting it in
since we're sharing did you know what is
running your critical behavior
you don't let it in and being able to
not let
in criticism that too will change your
life
it it makes you bulletproof you can't
stop being mean
and having a horrible day and we now
have trolling which is
becoming an epidemic so it's actually
worse our kids used to get bullied at
school
and go home to a sanctuary another
bullied online now they're bullied
online
on the phone and it's it never ends
and they feel really attacked and see
when you find
trolls they're usually really miserable
and unhappy but they love the power
because they have no power they live on
their own
or with their mum they have no life i
mean we had a terrible
situation in england where somebody was
trolling this person whose child had
been kidnapped and when they exposed her
she killed herself
which was a terrible thing for her but
obviously her sense of shame that she
was outed
and to kill herself but she must have
felt terrible i felt so sorry for her
but she was very vicious in her trolling
but that's a really unhappy person
she needed a lot of help but when you
can teach
people to come back from criticism
without fighting or going well i hate
you too
or you're all shut up or crying when you
can just teach them look
i'm not letting it it's like if i try to
give you a gift you go and i don't need
that gift i'm holding the gift
i can't give you something if you don't
take it i can't serve
papers on you unless you accept them i
can't serve a volley to you unless you
volley it back
so when you learn that people can try
and give you anything but if you don't
accept it
you haven't let it in and if you don't
let it in
it can't hurt you it just hurts the
person who's left holding it
well most people that come to me don't
go hey i've come to see you but
i don't want to give up my problem i
mean they do with food they go i want to
be super healthy
okay you're going to stop eating don't i
don't want to do that you've got
anything else there's a difference
between i don't want to do one thing
and i want to do it but i just i'm not
sure of the energy to see but you see
the belief is what you're
saying is it's work so much work it's
no work so what i would suggest for
someone like you is just
monitor hair you spit oh i forgot that
i've got terrible memory i got that i
didn't miss that gotta tell them
and start to say i have a phenomenal
memory i have an
outstanding i have a reliable foolproof
memory
so i saw with my daughter when she was
little she'd leave the house and come
back
because she has so much to remember her
school bag and her swimming stuff
and her lunch and i always say what have
you remembered because i remembered my
lunch
remembered my swimming okay that's so
great that you remember
and very quickly she went from oh
forgotten i got to go home my mum's
going to be really across to
no my memory is great at the gate it
told me
school lunch school coat and of course
if you go to any kid's classroom you'll
see coats and bags
they forget everything and we never go
well it's the memory you see
it disappears with age and i have people
of 90 who can tell you everything about
their childhood and what it was like in
the war
so you have to just make a decision to
tell yourself
i have an outstanding reliable
phenomenal incredible impressive
for perfect big words of course because
you want to excite you and if you say
enough your mind's job is to give you
that memory and then stop saying what
have i forgotten
say what have i remembered and then
something else you do is just say
that will come to me you know you have
to understand the mind a bit so when
you're dealing with a conscious mind the
subconscious doesn't do anything if
you're saying
what's the name of that book or that
restaurant
oh i don't know i give up i've got to
remember you just you suddenly goes oh
it's coming to my head
it was this book it was a tim ferriss
book i remember now because you've given
your mind an instruction
what is the name of that book your mind
will go and find it but if you are still
actively looking
it doesn't do it so we have something
good command
therapy you got to command your mind go
ahead and
remind me where my passport is remind me
and and so often it's just really poor
communication you know people say oh god
i'm flying to london tonight and
i can never fall asleep on a plane i
just can't
go to like well where are you going you
don't go anywhere you don't
fall you lie on the plane and you invite
sleep to come do you go i'm lying here
my eyes are heavy and sleep's descending
upon me
like a miss because it's a misdirect of
the mind because you don't
fall and you don't go but when you say
sleep is coming to me and when i
i'm in different time zones all over the
world i lie better go right
sleep now send sleep to me now i insist
on eight hours of sleep
i need eight hours and i tell my mind
what i want but i am
very clear very specific but not
can i fall asleep i need to look at it
i've got to get up in five hours and
now i'm stressed i just give my mind
very clear instructions
you do have to train yourself a bit but
if you
use those words my memory is impressive
and infallible your mind knows what that
looks like and it will make it real if
you just go
i need a better memory that's not
exciting
so excite it with powerful words and
you won't be surprised or you might how
much better it gets but you've got to
give up this belief that it's
work because talking to yourself isn't
work
exciting your mind doesn't work going to
the gym is work
but saying every day as you get up i've
got a great memory i can
even imagine my diary and i can see
what's in it
if you tell yourself that it'd actually
really becomes true and you'll notice
that everyone who's got a good memory
will say my memory is amazing
i have the best memory ever they never
go i've got mind like a sieve
i'd forget my head it wasn't screwed on
i would forget
the eyes in my head if they weren't
there but people with a poor memory they
justify they remind themselves how bad
it is instead of
deciding no i'm going to have a great
memory you know many many years ago i
was trying to get a book deal
and i'd put on a little talk
about how to lose weight because my book
was all about that and i hadn't sold
hardly any tickets
so i cancelled it and the same day my
agent called me went oh my gosh i've got
um
six different uh publishers who want to
come to your talk i'm like well i'll
just cancel this
put it back on quick because they're all
coming and it was that weekend and i
think she called me on a thursday night
so on the friday i rang
all my friends everyone said come to
this talk it's completely free
and and i got lots of people to come
because i knew that six
major publishing houses were coming to
this talk
and she told me one of them was
definitely going to give me a deal if
not all of them
so i only had friday and on friday i
could have spent ages
planning the talk but you know i didn't
i actually made a mood board i thought
that's a good thing so on friday night
i had an old picture and i took it out
of the frame
and i started to stick things in it and
i wrote marissa peer gets a great book
deal i i cut out the times
uh best selling list and i stuck it and
then wrote on it my book
you can be thin and i did lots and lots
of pictures that marissa makes people
thin i went through magazines i cut
stuff out
i wrote some checks out there i made
this mood bore really exciting and i
just looked at it
and looked at it and looked at it and it
made me so
excited about my talk and the next day i
went off and i did the talk and lo and
behold
at the end somebody came up to me and
she said oh my god i love that talk and
we want you to come in on monday and
we're going to offer you
a book deal straight away and we'd
really love you not to meet the other
five publishers we want you so that was
very exciting
and in fact i did end up signing with
them and it all was wonderful
but i know it was that mood board that
helped me because it took my mind to
where i wanted to be
it made me focus only on success of
course the mood board doesn't say things
like well i might not
make it the mood board has success so
let's imagine you want to be
a therapist that's what your vision is
or a photographer
maybe you want to be a chef i want you
to imagine you've got a mood board and
you
fill it up with pictures if you want to
be a chef
pictures of great food reviews from
restaurants and of course you're going
to cross out the name of the chef and
write your name in and said in black
marker pen
so find lots of reviews and put your
name in and then write
all over the mood board too let's say
your name is alexandra richardson
you're going to put alex richardson
instead of that chef and you're going to
put lots of reviews and
let's say you've found the top 10
best restaurants and you're going to
call your restaurant the fox
and so you cross that and you put the
fox alex richardson's restaurant the fox
and just keep looking at that and you
write all over your mood but all the
things that work for you
people love this restaurant the best
restaurant in wherever
you live in the world the food here is
amazing
and then you look at lots of interviews
with chefs and you imagine your
interview and you put it up there you
can even
mock one up that's what printers are for
so
mock up an interview mock up everything
and
look at that mood board mock up all the
things that you're going to cook that
are going to give you pleasure mock up
the cookery book you're going to write
mock up so much stuff you know
a couple of years ago i was asked to
work with probably the angriest kid i've
ever worked with
in my life and when we started to work
he said you know no one loves me i have
no love in my life and
i realized that his anger was actually
incredible pain but i talked to him
and i asked him what he was good at he
said nothing so i asked him what he
loved and he said cooking
so we talked about that a bit and he's
ended up being a phenomenally successful
chef he's got a great girlfriend he went
to work for other chefs he's now got his
own restaurant his life has changed
dramatically because i found
one thing that he loved and focused on
his purpose
and the reason he was here and he loved
cooking so much that i knew straight
away that that's what he was meant to do
and now he's doing and his life has
changed 360 degrees
mood boards have been proven over and
over again
to stimulate your brain to excite your
imagination to keep your
focus on where you want to go
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and how are you going to
take
action on it this week when you schedule
in what day what time and what place
you're going to take action you have a
91
chance of actually following through
versus just a 35
chance if you just got motivated but
never created a specific plan
and when you share your plan publicly
and have some accountability you
increase your chances even further
of actually following through so i want
to know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action this week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
i know that people say to you a lot of
times yes you're okay this is easy for
you
because nothing bad has ever happened to
you but you actually
had a and i don't i'm so curious to know
how you characterize it you had cancer
twice yeah um i was going to say battle
and then i thought i don't know that she
was yeah i didn't
use the word battle that's interesting
yeah so
one i'd love to hear how you do
conceptualize it of it
and then how you dealt with it i think
would be really powerful yeah would you
look at me say well you've had an
amazing life but you know my life wasn't
awful my father was a head master he was
very invested in other people's kids i
just felt like this kind of
hideous blob that wasn't interesting to
him at all and
both my parents told me i should be a
nanny because they obviously didn't see
any potential in me
at all but that isn't to diminish them
because i wouldn't change anything about
that because it made me have that i'll
prove you
attitude so i was thought i could never
ever have children and if i got pregnant
i would
never carry a baby to full term i
remember hearing that thinking you know
what i have to not let this
in and that's very important to make a
decision i will not
let that in so when i was told i
couldn't have a baby i thought i'm not
letting that in
and when i got pregnant i was told many
times you're going to lose the baby
she's going to be born with something
wrong with her
and i talked to her all the time and
told her to grow perfectly and
she did and when i was told i had cancer
i mean of course it's a
horrible thing to hear and i did spend
the first two days thinking oh my god
you know what am i going to go with this
but
because i've taught my mind for so long
to only go towards positive i found
myself on day three singing this song
and it was that song about
you know that song i feel pretty and
witty and wise but it was saying i'm
healing and my body is healing and it's
healing all the time and
i just made a decision to tell my body
look you you're gonna do wellness now
and
so i started to do wellness and i
visualized healing and i visualized it
being very contained and
i visualized myself bouncing back and
three weeks later i was on stage in
costa rica
not because i'm super because i told my
body uh listen i'm
i haven't got time to sit in this
hospital bed with medication
do wellness i i really did command my
body to recover
and it sounds like it's all right for
you but again you have to understand the
rules of the mind your body does what it
says if you go i'm ill
i've got cancer now it's bound to come
back and
always looking for signs people say to
me you know i'm a cancer survivor i'm
like oh no i'm not
i'm not because i don't have it so i was
obviously surprised when i got it again
but i just had to do the same thing and
say that's it now twice is enough for
anyone i'm i'm done with that and i
i don't refer to a huge amount um but i
started to think maybe
maybe it was good for me to get that
because i can look at other people say
listen you
always have a choice i mean i went home
the very next day i knew they gave me a
carry bag of drugs like what are they i
don't need those i didn't take
any medication and i just kept telling
my body but but i wasn't in any pain did
you do chemo
no no no no no drugs no chemo
what was the actual treatment i had
surgery twice to remove it and actually
the second time i now think i didn't
even need to have done that
did they want you to do chemo no i was
very lucky i got it
early on enough i didn't have to do it
but i don't think i ever would do that
not to diminish other people who have
but
you know again it's that choice tell
your body to do
wellness and i kept telling my body kill
the cancer annihilate the cancer
never called it my cancer that's my
cancer
because i've got my cancer back or i'm
going for
my cancer treatment and when you prefix
something with my you own it
you could look at my shoes aren't they
cool or my great t-shirt
but when you say my migraine my headache
my illness my
terrible memory if you put the word my
in front of something it's yours
and if you call it the it's not yours so
i was very committed to never saying my
it wasn't mine i didn't want it i felt
very lucky that i got in an organ that i
didn't need that was completely
dispensable so that was
good if you want to change your life for
free in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below or if you want
some awesome motivation from mel robbins
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there